one of the most defining experiences in
my life was living in Moscow for two
years it's uh really where I feel like I
became an artist I got to study at the
the famous Moscow Art Theater you know
it was chekhov's theater with
stanislavsky's theater Moscow was
completely alive and you could feel this
sense of history that was palpable on
the streets because so many of the
people that I I studied with and learned
from you know they had grown up under a
completely different kind of system
during Soviet Times Public Gatherings
were outlawed there was no way to get
together and to express ideas and to
share ideas the only place really where
you could do that was in the theater in
these State sanctioned theaters and the
art that was made in these theaters had
to have a pro-state message meyerhold
who was one of the most revered
directors in the history of the Moscow
Art Theater and meyerhold was
assassinated by the KGB in his apartment
there's a palpability of this kind of
danger that exists on the street of
Moscow the brutality of that City at
times really sickened me I was also
overwhelmed by the beauty of the people
and the beauty of the spirit and the
beauty of the art it's also given me
this sense of of such a deep
appreciation for this country and how
sacred this Freedom that we have is we
spoke to uh one of my very dear friends
uh in Russia these are dangerous times
and I think that this perspective uh is
unbelievably valuable I hope you listen
with an open heart and again this is the
perspective of uh somebody who I
consider to be one of the realest ones
out there
[Music]
man I love you man it's good to see your
face
love you too brother and great to see
you I mean I I know there's been
so much that's that's that's happened
since the last time that that we spoke
and uh one of the huge challenges here
is just the difference with information
and and getting Clarity and I'm just
wondering
you know how how you are how you're
seeing things you know the big news
that's that's reaching us is you know
because of the the pushback in the in
the north there's this draft that's been
instituted and I'm I'm just wondering
you know how you can sort of explain the
state of things right now
I
well as you as you know the situation
changes kind of by the day if not by the
hour
recently I just read the news that uh
Putin is going to he's going to announce
the annexation of all those regions that
kind of you know voted to join Russia
well that's going to be a game changer
can you explain why that's going to be a
game changer
well he's escalating he keeps escalating
and uh the West will have to respond to
it somehow yet they they are in the way
they are saying that this is an
acceptable nobody's going to accept the
fact that those territories belong to
Russia so it's unconstitutional and it's
it's wrong anyway
and soldiers go there it's as if Rush is
being attacked exactly so the whole idea
behind that plan that he has is that
this this is now Russian territory and
if uh this territory is attacked by the
ukrainians or by with the Western
weapons
so it means they are taking Russia and
Russia
have all the legitimate right to respond
and uh and it seems and many people more
and more people say those who comment on
it they say that he is looking for a
reason to use nuclear tactical nuclear
weapons what what do you personally
think about that
oh he's heading that direction obviously
I mean it's not a secret he is sick it's
not a secret that he's
you know as they say here with one foot
in the Deathbed so he kind of doesn't
care he seems like he wants to drag
if not the whole world but you know a
couple of countries he went to drive to
that grave when you say there's it's no
secret that he's sick it's no secret
that he's in the Deathbed
I understand the reports of his own
personal health the last time we spoke
you talked about so many in Russia
supporting the war because of a lack of
information and Clarity of what's
happening but but but now you have
hundreds of thousands of of young men
fleeing the country what is sort of
public opinion like these days has it
has it shifted massively like are there
still many who are very supportive of
the the the war
yeah but listen we we don't know what
the public opinion is because you know
nobody is doing surveys and nobody's is
calling people because people are not
going to in this situation nobody is
going to honestly tell you what they
really think
but but you being there and knowing
people are talking yeah but but you know
the the people I know they all of them
don't support the war
and uh actually many of them fleeed
recently A couple of my colleagues they
left the country and a friend of mine
just recently she with her two children
she was driving up to
Latvia to cross the border thank God she
has an Israeli passport so she
she's gonna go to Israel
through the boiler and she said that
there is a huge line on the Latvia
border of ukrainians who are trying to
enter Europe so
um the opinion is that nobody can see
this is where I have this is where I
have trouble you know people here they
don't have arms and it seems that that's
the only way to stop it
is to uh for the armed people to
confront it wow
uh people don't have arms you know those
those protesters who go on the on the
rallies they immediately uh taken to to
jail
and they prosecuted right away and they
are mutilated
and they can't do anything I mean
literally if you go to Rally you have to
go there with a baseball bat
and you have to fight otherwise it
doesn't make any sense there because you
it's really like a sacrifice for nothing
I know you know many people who go to
those those rallies
it's it's this is what's happening to
them they're getting mutilated there oh
yeah I just recently you know there was
a report there was this young boy who
under his 20 I think and he was reading
poetry near the mayakovsky monument you
remember that Michael Square Monument so
he was doing poetry there so he was
arrested
and they rape him with the uh
with the dumbbell in police station John
it's like you can't you can't appeal to
them saying you know stop the war please
don't do it please don't kill people
because those guys they they kind of
cross that line already so I mean the
situation is such that now it can be
stopped only by force there is no any
other way
it can be stopped because it's it's
right it's rolling down the hill
and uh and you know all these say
peaceful measures are exhausted that's
why I'm saying you know it's it it
really it does look like ending because
Russia is let alone you know the Ukraine
is uh devastated and so many people are
killed and all that but Russia is
is ruined completely
completely ruined how so can you can you
give me examples well you see the the
most of the uh working man
uh talented people they flee the country
tens of thousands of people are sent to
the war to be just slaughtered there
because they don't have and and it's you
know let alone that they go there like
sheep sent to a Slaughter and they don't
even question why they ascend there and
what they're going to do that it doesn't
even cross their mind they're going to
be killing peaceful people civilians uh
some of them was asked will they go
there and they say yes we will because
we don't want to be in prison so for you
it's better to go and kill someone
rather than to be in prison it's and you
know that's the kind of a shift in
values
it's beyond you know it's beyond as they
stay good and evil it's out of control I
mean historically I I with all kinds of
different
you know systems of government in place
I feel like Russia has sent so many
people to the front lines I mean it's
it's it's it happened in World War II
yeah Is this different is this people
you know people say oh War experts say
that with Russia does Russia is fighting
on a World War II method so to speak you
know they're using all the same tools
that they used in World War II they're
just sending as many people as they can
to the front line so nobody cares about
people here you know they they do call
them like Canon Porter and send them to
the front line and they think you know
by doing this in 21st century so they'll
win the war and they they kind of don't
understand that now they're facing
military equipment that wasn't available
in World War II since Ukraine is given
this equipment Ukraine now can can kill
all of them without even you know they
say that now they don't even have bullet
wounds anymore right right it's like
people are just being blown up yeah
that's all all
yeah I was reading that a nurse was
saying that that her whole time there
she hasn't seen a single person with a
bullet wound
yeah yeah
and the Recently I saw I saw this video
somebody uh in one of the telegram
channels
they posted this video where I think it
was one of the conscripts who uh shot
this video on his phone
and posted it and this is uh this is
like a lieutenant this woman she's
instructing those to those men who
adopted what they have to have with them
because you know the Army does not
provide them with all the necessary like
first aid kits and stuff so they have to
buy it all themselves and she's saying
buy tampons and buy all these things
because it's so it's very good for the
bullet one you can stick the top on in
the bullet wound and it'll it'll stop
bleeding you know she's like instructing
them to where to buy like tell them tell
your family they need to buy it all for
you because we we except for the for the
equipment we're not going to give you
anything else and these guys are going
there anyway
well I mean this is like this is
mind-blowing and sometimes you know you
even think when you think about it when
they show when they show this footage
from from the rallies in Moscow you kind
of think to yourself you know this
policeman you know fully guarded with
all this armor on they they're beating
women they're beating girls and there is
no men there around who would fight for
them who would fight for the girls and
if even there is one guy who would fight
for the girls I mean nobody is
supporting him there are no other men
who would support him a policeman in
Moscow right now that's doing that
that's beating on a a young woman who's
protesting in his heart do you think he
thinks he's doing the right thing or do
you think he's doing what he feels like
he has to do can you try to explain to
me the psychology of of that of that I
have no idea John I mean this is like I
would say the moment they did that this
is when they lost their Humanity
[Music]
[Music]